Now consider the relationship between
work, transfers, and execution time.
Suppose the processor takes tau
time units to perform an operation.
Thus, the time to perform just
the compute operations is tau times
the work, W.
Next, let alpha be the amortized time to
move one word of data between slow and
fast memory.
Alpha has units of time per word.
Then the time to execute Q
transfers is alpha times L times Q.
Now let's assume perfect overlap
between data transfer and compute.
Then the minimum time to execute
the program would be the maximum
of the time to compute, and
the time to move the data.
Let's refactor this expression a little.
This refactoring shows the execution
time relative to the ideal running time,
which is just tau times W.
It's ideal in the sense that it
assumes data movement is free.
Now relative to this ideal computation
time, you need to pay a penalty.
This communication or transfer
penalty is the price you pay for
having to move the data.
Now this penalty has some structure.
Let's start with the denominator
of the second argument.
Why it's nothing more than
the algorithms computational intensity.
Recall that intensity has
units of operations per word.
Now what about the numerator?
The numerator is th time per word
divided by the time per operation.
It's a ratio of parameters that
only depend on the machine.
In the literature, it's sometimes
referred to as the machine's balance
point, or just machine balance.
And just like intensity,
it has units of operations per word.
In other words, this ratio tells you
how many operations can be executing in
the time that it takes
to move a word of data.
Machine balance is kind of
a special parameters, so
let's replace it with a symbol,
capital B.
That's B as in buzz.
Okay, so what we have now
is a general formula for
the minimum possible execution time in
terms of the balance of the machine and
the intensity of the algorithm.
For completeness we could also
estimate the maximum time for
computation in this model.
It's basically the sum
rather than the max.
That's because if there's no overlap,
you have to pay for computation and
communication one after the other.
Okay, so we have a formula to
estimate the minimum execution time.
Sometimes, rather than
asking about execution time,
we'll ask about a certain
measure of performance.
I'll denote that measure by R.
Its numerator is tao times W star.
In other words,
the best time in the pure RAM model.
So what does dividing by T do?
Why?
It gives you the following formula.
It says the best possible value of
the normalized performance is W star
over W times the min of one and
intensity divided by balance.
This measure of performance is
inversely proportional to time.
Therefore higher values are better.
Take a moment to ponder it as you'll
explore it in more depth momentarily.